welcome back our next guest is sounding
the alarm from the front lines of the
border crisis
the mayor of laredo texas begging a
federal judge
to stop the buses packed with pos
covet positive migrants from flooding
into a city
this is more than 280 migrants have been
taken to laredo shelters
since sunday at least 75 of them are
coveted positive that's about 25 percent
are coveted positive laredo texas mayor
pete simon joins us right now
mayor good morning to you yes good
morning steve thank you for uh taking
interest in the border
it's a great interest to everybody that
is why you had to declare a disaster the
other day
to ask a judge please tell the federal
government to stop flooding our streets
with these coveted positive migrants
and migrants in general we just don't
have enough room right
absolutely yeah we've been it's truly a
crisis it's a triple crisis we have a
border security crisis we have a health
crisis here
in our city in the area and of course we
have a humanitarian crisis
as well and it's all as a result of this
huge
influx of migrants that are coming in uh
throughout the entire border area and of
course laredo is no exception
our situation is compounded because we
we have migrants being bust
to the laredo area because the rgb which
is a
about 150 miles down river of laredo
is just overwhelmed i think they've had
over 400 thousand
migrants uh since october first i
believe
so uh you know we're we're now the the
place where they're bringing these
migrants for further processing
yesterday we did reach an agreement with
the border patrol and
so there's no need to to continue the
lawsuit
but it's temporary now the city of
laredo proper with
with taxpayer money we're financing the
busing
of these migrants further north uh into
texas
uh so they can reach their destinations
right um
so it's it's it's become so complicated
uh steve
no kidding and mayor the president was
asked the other day
about you know he's concerned with uh
people in this country having
coveted but at the same time our
southern border seems to be wide open
and the president
cited title 42 saying we're turning
everybody around at the border
saying you can't come in because of
covid he said the only people being let
in
are children you're seeing the people
i'm looking at the video they're letting
in a lot more than just
kids absolutely and it's called it's
these family units and of course they
they bring the children so the family
members can also uh
tag along and again it's the asylum
seekers the policy is there
but obviously the sometimes something's
terribly wrong here
it's not orderly there's chaos and
obviously it's creating this crisis that
we're facing here
uh throughout the entire border area so
we're asking for resources have you
if you're insisting in this policy
enforce it uh
uh you know uh make it
work uh right totally on the federal you
know nickel
i don't expect the locals to uh you know
to uh to expend
monies you know to to help the federal
government uh
we can do our part okay that's what we
can do if the feds are gonna ask you to
take all these people they should at
least help you with the money
and you could use it uh mayor pete signs
of laredo sir thank you very much i know
you got your hands full thanks for
starting your morning with us thank you
very much take care